AMY WALGENBACH: Hi everyone.
My name is Amy Walgenbach, and
I am a product marketing
manager for Google+.
And I'm really excited to be
here today to talk to you all
about how to grow your audience
with Google+.
Just one housekeeping note is
that this is being recorded,
so you don't need to take notes
or anything unless, of
course, you'd like to.
So to get a little sense of
things, how many of you guys
have an app that you're
trying to grow?
And of those people that have
their hands up, how many of
you feel like you already have
an active presence on Google+?
For those of you that are not
raising your hand, you are
making a mistake.
So it's my goal to convince you
all why it's important to
have an active presence and to
give you some practical advice
on how to use the platform
to grow your business.
Let's get started.
How do I turn it on?
All right, so the agenda
is really simple.
I'm just going to go into a
little bit of background about
Google+ and then spend the bulk
of the time talking to
you about what you
should be doing.
And then we'll save some time
for questions at the end.
So what exactly is Google+?
We've been compared to social
networks, identity log ins,
and even at an earlier talk
today I heard someone ask if
Google+ was trying to be
a blogging platform.
So our approach is simple.
Google+ is an effort to enhance
your Google experience
by adding your identity so we
know a little bit more about
you, the notion of your
relationships and sharing.
So instead of trying to explain
to you what makes
Google+ so special, I thought
I'd start with a video about
some of the engagement
we've seen over the
past year on the platform.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-We're the first ones that
are doing it like this.
It's history!
-I have a new single that I
really want to premiere.
-Google+, this is Houston.
-[SPEAKING JAPANESE].
-Because when you are talking to
a late night comedian, the
best thing to do is to probably
get his thoughts on
the colonization of
other planets.
-Touchdown [INAUDIBLE].
-[CHEERING]
-Wow.
-[SQUEALING].
-Hi everyone.
It's Ellie.
I'm going to sign this
album right here.
What would you like
me to write?
-Can I hug you?
-How does it feel
to go that fast?
-You're just gliding along.
-What is it that drives you?
-I love track and field.
The fame, the downfalls.
For me the work is intense but
I want to be a legend.
-That's the biggest thing
that you can do in life.
You have to dream.
-I'm going over.
-Mr. President, welcome
to Google+.
-Thanks everybody.
-I couldn't be more excited to
bring you into my world.
-I'm from Germany.
-Chile.
-Regards from [INAUDIBLE].
-Everybody say hi.
That's the whole world.
-Hi.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
AMY WALGENBACH: So people all
over the world are using
Google+ to connect to people
they've never met before but
with whom they share a common
interest, a shared passion.
Whether it be music, sports,
politics or even space travel,
people are forging real
relationships and connecting
face to face on Google+.
And this community is large,
and it continues to grow.
What we've seen is over 390
million people are taking
social actions across Google.
And that's things like +1ing
their favorite app in the
Google Play store or writing
a review of their favorite
restaurant using their
real identity.
And on Google+, we've seen this
active community be about
190 million 30-day active users
in the Google+ stream.
These numbers were just
released yesterday.
And our active users
are highly active.
They're sharing with
friends, joining
Hangouts, uploading photos.
Simply put, Google+ is huge.
And it just continues to grow.
So it's not an audience
that you can ignore.
So now you're probably thinking,
OK, this is really
impressive.
But how do I use this?
How do I take advantage of
all of this activity?
And we've spent a lot of time
talking to developers and
companies just like you guys.
And we've talked to those
that are most active
on Google+ and learned.
And what we've heard is that
Google+ is enabling better
discoverability of your apps.
It's creating a new breed of
more personal engagement, like
getting face to face in a
Hangout or connecting around
common interests.
And third, it's helping extend
the value of Social to your
site and apps.
So let's take a closer look
about each of these, starting
with how Google+ can help you
get discovered across Google.
And the importance of great
content, whether you create it
yourself or you partner with a
content creator, is critical
for your marketing.
With an active Google+ page,
Google can help you surface
your post content in many
ways across Google.
And I'm going to show you a
couple ways where your content
can be discovered.
And one of the most important
times we surface your content
is in Google Search.
So what I'm going to do now is
show you the most amazing and
groundbreaking way you can
double the size of your
footprint in Google Search.
Are you ready?
So in this example, this is
SoundCloud's Google+ page.
They're active.
They're posting regularly.
The page is verified.
And they're using Google+
Sign In to send
activities to Google.
So let's take a look at what's
going on with them in Search.
Before Google+, a search for
SoundCloud yielded a bunch of
blue links.
But thanks to their active
Google+ presence, they have an
incredibly more compelling,
engaging and
relevant search presence.
I mean, it's very visual.
Your eye is just drawn towards
that right hand side.
And you can see on that right
hand side, there's their
Profile Icon.
There's a Follow button so that
users can add them to
their Circles directly
from search.
Below, because they're an active
page, real time content
is surfaced.
So you can see their
most recent post.
And also, you can see aggregate
and trending
activity from users, user
activity from within that app.
So if you integrate Google+ Sign
In app activities, user
activity from your app
can be seen from
branded search queries.
And these links deep link
into your content.
So this is an incredible amount
of real estate they're
getting because they have an
active presence on Google+.
And it doesn't cost
them any money.
They don't need to
pay for this.
And it's seen to every Google
user, not just those that are
following them.
It's pretty powerful.
So this is great, when someone
is specifically looking for
your brand.
But what about when someone's
searching for a generic,
non-branded term?
So here's a search for a summer
cocktail, something I'm
looking forward to
after this talk.
And something that you wouldn't
normally tend to see
branded content appear.
But Martha Stewart, the Food
Network and Marie Claire
content shows up because I
follow them in Google+.
So this is a prime example
of how Google+ can drive
discovery of some of
your best content.
And it shapes brand
awareness and
consideration sets in the process.
So if you've ever pondered
the value of a
follower, this is it.
This is your answer.
You can reach more people who
follow you on Google+ with
your content in ways that
you couldn't before.
So their content wouldn't have
appeared for me in the Search
Results if I hadn't been
following them in Google+.
And I wouldn't have clicked on
that link for a margarita.
So your followers will see your
content in Search across
a variety of topics, re-engaging
them back to you.
So the more followers you have,
the more people you have
a chance to reach with
your content.
And another great example of
this is seen in Search Ads.
How many of you use AdWords?
OK, a couple.
So this will be relevant
for you guys.
So with a Google+ page, an
active page, and with Social
Annotations enabled in AdWords,
Google surfaces
follower count.
And on average, Search Ads with
these annotations perform
about 5% to 10% higher.
So this means that your Search
then gets more efficient and
you get more traffic.
And not only are social
recommendations sending you
more traffic, but they're also
getting you better, more
qualified traffic.
They're driving conversions
and can ultimately have a
significant effect on
your bottom line.
And the best part is, is that
if you have an Enhanced
Campaign in AdWords enabled
already, then you don't need
to do this.
It's automatic.
Pretty cool.
And it's not just about getting
your content into
Google Search.
It's about getting your content
across all of Google.
So here's an example.
My friend Christian sent me
a post about an app that I
should check out.
A couple weeks ago, some
members of the Google+
marketing team, we went
on a juice cleanse.
And right before I/O was
probably not the best time for
a juice cleanse, but
we made it through.
And he recommended this app for
me to use if I was tired.
And so when I went to the Google
Play store, I saw that
over 20 of my friends had +1ed
that app, creating powerful
social proof to download
the app.
So this example is meant to show
that people who follow
your brand, they're more
likely to share it on
Google+ and +1 it.
So having engaged followers
helps you get more +1's, which
helps you get discovered.
And we've even begun to expand
this concept to other
properties like YouTube.
So in this case, the only reason
this Ford video shows
up in my YouTube feed
is because I
follow them on Google+.
And on a more personalized
level, the only reason this
Dodge RAM video shows up, is
because my friend Christian,
who I follow on Google+,
shared it.
So if Ford, Dodge, and Christian
hadn't shared these
videos via Google+, I never
would have found them.
The point is, sharing videos
in Google+ drives social
discoverability in YouTube.
So if you have a page and you
share video content, the more
followers you have, the more
opportunity it is for your
video content to
appear to them.
So now that we've heard some
ways on how you can get your
content to spread across Google+
and Google, let's talk
about how you can make
this happen.
So building your presence
starts with a page.
And you really want
to be posting
rich content regularly.
And as I mentioned before, the
more followers you have, the
bigger opportunity for people
to discover your brand.
And of course, in order to get
that great effect and to
increase your imprint in Google
Search, you want to
send app activities via
Google+ Sign In
to Google as well.
And I want to give you some
tips for posting great
content, because I think
it's so important.
You want to create a posting
schedule, to post at least
once a day.
You can ask questions or share
insight or content.
Plus, mention your communities
so that they feel the love and
will reshare your
content as well.
And don't just share
any photos.
Share exclusive photos.
And if you edit your photos in
Google+, we can automatically
turn them into an animated GIF,
which can really make
them pop out as well.
And if you don't have the
resources to manage your
social presence yourself, we
work with several social media
management companies that can
help you do this, that have
integrated with our platform.
Companies like Hearsay Social
or HootSuite or
even our own Wildfire.
So Starbucks is one of the
most savvy social media
companies we can
all learn from.
If you look at their last few
posts, they're getting between
500 to 1,000 +1's and about 50
to 100 comments per post.
So I'm going to show you
some lessons that we've
learned from them.
And just copy this.
It's a playbook for
a successful page.
So starting out, one of the
things that we've noticed
they've done is they have an
animated GIF as their cover
photo, which really
makes that pop.
And their magic formula
is simple.
They have one attractive and
simple photo per post.
Sometimes it's a video, but
mostly it's a photo.
They have, like, one line
of text and maybe
a hashtag or two.
And the hashtags now appear at
the top of your post you
create, as well as
related hashtags.
So they can be an important
way for your content to be
discovered as well.
And they include offers
in their posts.
It's kind of hard to tell from
this, but this is an offer.
And you feel good about gifting
it to your loved ones
by resharing it.
And you get material value
from the post as well.
And they have authentic photos,
not stock photos.
So it looks like they put more
thought into it rather than
just posting without thinking.
And they're asking the
community questions.
So it really creates
that interaction.
And they're also posting
infographics, which can also
be superviral.
And they have occasion
driven posts.
So this is a post from the
Kentucky Derby that they did.
They've also done some
for Mother's
Day and other occasions.
But it really captures that
top of mind, feel good
sentiment the audience has.
So you guys, one recommendation
is to have a
posting calendar that mirrors
special occasions or topical
news events related to your
brand and business.
So cute and resharable posts
create virality.
It's very clever thinking.
Your first emotional response
is to want to share it.
And one of the most effective
ways to grow your followers is
by adding the Google+
badge to your site.
Hopefully we've all now learned
the value of a follower.
And it comes in a variety of
shapes and sizes, but at its
core, it lets people know that
you're on Google+ and add you
to their Circles directly.
And you should add the badge,
not just to your website, but
to your emails, your blog, any
offline campaigns that you're
doing, or anything that you
have, in-store signage.
In this example, Britney Spears
plastered it on her
homepage of her website.
Your page should be part of
your business strategy.
And you can also advertise, if
you'd like to also help gain
more followers, on our GDN or
in Google Search as well.
And what we found is that top
publishers who installed the
badge grew their audience
by 38% on average.
That's pretty amazing for
such minimal work.
The badge is so easy to add.
You should do it today.
And you really want to give
people a reason to
come to your page.
It's just a more natural way to
get more followers, is to
just drive them to some sort of
content or programming that
you're doing, like
with a Hangout.
So it feels more natural to
tell them to come and join
your page if you have something
going on there.
Which brings us to
our next point of
engagement and Hangouts.
So now that we've learned what
you should be doing on Google+
to help get discovered, let's
shift to talk about how
Google+ is also enabling you
to create deeper and more
personal relationships
with your users.
And because I'm in marketing and
love videos, I just want
to show you one more video of
how one brand, Cadbury, is
using Hangouts On Air to
create a more personal
engagement with their users.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Actually it's always been to
see what's different about
Google+ to other social
networks.
The thing that's most different
is Hangouts.
You can't really do it on
any other platform.
We've done three Hangouts
so far.
The first one we created a
chocolate version of our
Google+ page.
Then we did a second one with
Rebecca Adlington, one of the
Olympians we're sponsoring
and supporting.
And we've just met up with one
of our chocolate tasters and
gone for an informal
discussion on
the basics of chcolate.
We spent quite a long time
with our first Hangout,
thinking, what will we
do, when will we do.
We made it complicated
in our head.
And the reality was, it's as
easy as having a conversation
with someone face-toface.
-I think it's really cool for a
company as big as Cadbury to
actually be communicating
with customers.
-My favorite thing about
Hangouts On Air is the ability
to have as many close
connections-- this small group
of people-- but do it in a
way that lets thousands
of people see it.
-So Rebecca, how many laps
do you run in a day.
-I do about 7,000 to 8,000
in a session and I do
10 sessions a week.
-There's something quite
powerful about sitting in
front of someone, essentially
eye-to-eye, and having a chat.
It's a new frontier, and it's
something that technology two
years wouldn't have
allowed us to do.
-I really like like dark
chocolate with caramelized
orange in it.
-Hangout is a really amazing way
of building that personal
connection with fans,
So I would say,
brands, give it a try.
Think about new ways of
connecting with your consumers
and having a chat with them.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
AMY WALGENBACH: OK.
So Cadbury's using Hangouts to
take social brand engagement
to a more personal level.
And some ways that we've seen
Hangouts be used for other
companies is to debut exclusive
content or do a
behind the scenes look
at your company or
your office or something.
You can also get feedback
from users.
So we've also seen it used as
a customer service channel.
And you really want to create
those moments that matter, to
drive deeper and more meaningful
relationships with
your followers.
And another example by Cadbury,
to celebrate the fact
that they had surpassed 2.5
million followers and to debut
the new flavor of their Dairy
Milk chocolate bar, they
created a Google+ Event for
unveiling their new flavor and
sent some of their biggest fans
a sample of the chocolate
bar, where in a Hangout, they
all unveiled the bar together
and tried it for
the first time.
And it was pretty cool.
Because we saw friendships
form, relationships that
happened were--
they kept the conversation
going even after
the Hangout had ended.
So it was pretty amazing.
And if you're wondering, the
flavor was Bubbly Mint, which
I personally have not tried but,
from the Hangout, looked
pretty amazing.
So this February, Topshop
reinvented its fashion show
and simultaneously democratized
the thrill of
London Fashion Week, something
notoriously exclusive.
They partnered with us in a
groundbreaking series of
inventive online happenings,
that I really feel was an
amazing game changer
for fashion.
And this was such an
exceptional, well executed
campaign, I could
go on and on.
But I really just want to focus
on two parts that I
think you guys will
be interested in.
The first was the Be The Model
component afforded a rare
opportunity for fans to
get a model's eye
view of Fashion Week.
There were Hangouts with
the top models.
And at Topshop's flagship store,
fans could enter a
special Google+ booth where
they try on their favorite
look and take a picture, and
it would upload it to the
Google+ Event Page, which really
bridged that online and
offline gap.
And Be the Buyer component saw
the launch of a Hangout app
where for the first time in
fashion history, users could
pick and choose their favorite
items and share them with
their friends in a Hangout.
So Topshop rewarded its best
collection of outfits with a
Fabulously Free Shopping
Spree as well.
And they promoted this Hangout
app exhaustively
on their home page.
And there was a leader board of
the most shared items from
the Hangout app.
So what they did with this data
is that Topshop used it
to help its buyers decide what
they're going to actually
bring to market.
So what's really cool about this
is that Topshop fans get
to influence the buying
decision.
And what they saw was that
there was about 300,000
followers to their page because
of this event in the
two weeks leading up to it.
And they had about 300% increase
in metrics like +1's
and reshares and comments
per post.
And they had really good
engagement in their Hangout
app as well.
So when we look to the future
of social experience online,
it's our goal to give you the
tools to make any experience
more social, personal
and meaningful.
So a Page lets you talk
to your fans.
And a Community lets
your users talk to
each other about you.
So Google+ Communities
are about
connecting people and passions.
They're a place for individuals,
organizations and
businesses to meet and share
based on a common interest.
And one way we've seen this work
is to build a community
based on a topic that's
related to your brand.
So in this case, this is
Lowe's Community Page.
They built this Geek Your Home
community, where users can get
together and share tips on
how to geek out your pad.
And what's great is that
Lowe's is part of that
conversation.
And one of the other ways we've
seen Communities work is
that you can listen to what
your customers are saying,
both about your brand or topics
that are relevant to
your business.
So you should really create a
lasting impression by getting
face to face with your
users in Hangouts.
So that's sort of like one of
the ways we recommend you to
grow your audience
with engagement.
And then also create a more
social branded experience by
creating a Hangout app.
And then we recommend
participating in creating
Communities as well, which
is another great way.
And you can also listen to your
fans that way and hear
what they have to say.
So Google+ can also help you
achieve deeper engagement with
your users, both on
your site and app.
So this is where the Google+
platform comes in.
And I'm not going to go too
deep into the platform,
because there's been a lot
of sessions about it.
I just want to briefly touch
on a couple of points here.
One example that we launched
on Monday is content
recommendations for your
mobile website.
So when you help someone find a
great article on your site,
you're not only making them
happier, you're inspiring
deeper engagement and loyalty.
So if you have a mobile website,
you should add this.
And this is an example from
Forbes, where visitors to
their mobile website can
now easily discover
other content on Forbes.
And this is an example, when you
integrate Google+ Sign In
into your site, there's an
authentication dialog
box that pops up.
And one of the scopes that you
can have is with our YouTube
API, so that when you sign in to
a site, you can also follow
their YouTube channel
at the same time.
So it's kind of connecting
your presence.
They can follow your page later
on, but when you sign
in, it's a great way to get more
followers to your YouTube
channel as well.
One of the most impressive
features of Google+ Sign In is
something we call Over
The Air Installs.
So when a user signs in on the
web, they can automatically
choose to download your app to
their mobile phone without
them ever leaving your site or
touching their device, which
is pretty cool.
And interactive posts allow
users to bring others they
care about into your app.
Users can send posts asking
people to sign up, write a
review, register, buy something
or whatever
your app calls for.
In this example, Seth wants to
send a menu to Ardon and
shared it on Google+.
And then you see what the share
looks like for Ardon in
the stream.
And you see a View
Menu button?
That's the really powerful
piece, is that there's a
clickable call to action
embedded directly
in a Google+ post.
So this new call to action
allows you to not only share
your content to a growing
audience but to also direct
users what they should be
doing next in your app.
Give them a reason to go
there and do something.
So if it isn't already clear by
all of the Google+ Sign In
talks at I/O, it's important.
And it is the way to integrate
Google+ into your apps.
And right after this talk, Danny
Bernstein is moderating
a panel with a bunch
of our partners.
So if you want to hear directly
from partners, you
should go to that talk.
It's in Room 8 after this.
And you should go talk to the
companies in our Sandbox on
how they're integrating
Google+ Sign In.
We have a ton of companies
there, and perhaps it can
spark some ideas for you.
So here's really the
three things you
should be doing on Google+.
Your presence starts
with a page.
So creating an active page
is really important.
And engage with your audience.
It's about making a lasting
impression with them.
If a user participates in a
Hangout or joins a Community
you manage, they can feel more
connected to you, and it
inspires deeper engagement
and loyalty.
And this can turn a fan
into a brand advocate.
And last but not least, is
Google+ Sign In, which is
critical to using Google+ to
create more engagement and
drive more qualified traffic
to your app.
So these are the three things
you should be doing today.
So to sum it up, it's about
getting discovered across
Google, engaging with your
audience, and making Google+
work for you.
I said at the beginning it was
my goal to try and convince
you all why it was important to
have a presence on Google+.
And I hope I've done that.
So if I have, here are some
resources for you guys on ways
to get started.
Thank you very much.
And now we can take
some questions.
So if you have any questions,
there's two mics right here,
if you just want to go there.
And I have a special guest who
might help me out with some
questions as well,
Mr. Marvin Chow.
AUDIENCE: John Blossoms,
Shore Communications.
On the Sign In, it's great
because it helps people get to
your site and get
engaged more.
And you've shown a lot of the
tools for brand engagement.
But traditional editorial
sources may or may not feel
limited by the amount of
information they get from the
Sign In to be able to serve up
the right sort of content.
What are the sort of strategies
that help people
use Google+ to have the right
experience for them when they
come to visit your site?
AMY WALGENBACH: Yeah, I think
one really important thing
that we've seen is, with
the mobile content
recommendations, it's really
great for those publishers who
are able to see more
recommendations for content
and share that activity
right into their app.
Sorry.
We're just micing up here.
Everyone, this is Marvin Chow.
He's the global director of
marketing for Google+.
He's here to help
me out as well.
I don't know if that answered
your question.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Hi.
I'm Spencer Richardson
from FanBridge.
The question is about the role
and potential mash up between
YouTube subscribers and Google+
followers, because we
work with a lot of video
creators both in the brand
space, SMB, as well as
MCNs, all those guys.
And as we convinced them about
the amazing things that
Google+ Brand Pages and so forth
has to offer, we get the
question of, do they have to
reinvent their understanding
of subscribers within Google?
AMY WALGENBACH: Yeah, and I
think we've done a lot to
bridge those two together.
You're seeing a lot of
activation between YouTube and
Google+, where now you can have
your channel, direct it
and combine it with your page,
so that you really only need
one presence on Google
if you're a brand.
And that's part of, it's the
same channel, the same page,
so that a user knows where to
go to follow you across both
of those platforms.
I think we have some
work to do.
But a lot of people have
invested time into their
YouTube presence.
So we know that's also an
important channel for people.
MARVIN CHOW: And I'll
add a little bit.
I think we all see the
tremendous opportunity between
YouTube and Google+ .
And I think, as you've seen
from Larry, this bringing
together Google is a priority
longer term.
And I think the first phase is
this merging of identity.
Google+ is about identity.
So if you're Company X on
YouTube and you're Company X
on Google+, we want to
know you're the same
person and who you are.
Once we can verify that,
with the merge, we'll
start to mix the graph.
So unintentionally, but if a
page is sharing something on
Google+ and they're following
you on YouTube or not, we'll
have an idea of what type of
content to begin to surface in
what Amy showed.
Now, longer and longer term, you
can obviously see that we
want to coalesce to one action
that we want a user to take as
it relates to an
entity, whether
it's follow or subscribe.
And how do those things
come together?
And we're working that out.
I think because YouTube does
not have verification, they
don't have an idea
of identity.
It's very hard, because some
brands have 100 YouTube
channels but they only have
one Google+ page.
So we're working through a lot
of the complexity of small
businesses, app developers,
large brands.
But we want to get to the point
where you as a developer
or brand have a single presence
across Google that
you can do different things
with your audience with.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
With the search results, where
you've got your brand up
there, is there any way to
influence that, to kind of
modify what's going
to be shown on the
Search Results page?
AMY WALGENBACH: Well, there
are certain things
that you could do.
Like if you have an active page,
it surfaces your most
recent posts.
So for your branded search
query, it'll
show what you're posting.
So that would be one way.
And also, you can decide
what activities
you're writing to Google.
So that's the aggregated data
that we're using to surface
those activities in Google, in
the right hand side of the
search results.
So there's that way as well.
So you can tell Google, send
this activity every time
someone watches a trailer
or buys something.
So that's the activity that
could potentially be shown.
We've just started with apps in
the music and movie space.
But we will be expanding
to others.
AUDIENCE: Right.
Because right now it shows
your logo, the ability to
follow, and then some
recent posts.
But no, maybe, posts that I'm
especially proud of, or stuff
that I think is a better example
of the kind of content
that we provide.
MARVIN CHOW: Yeah.
I think, the most recent posts,
and when you search for
an app or a brand, we want to
show the most recent activity.
I think that's one big thing.
The profile photo is your
profile photo from Google+.
You have some flexibility
there.
I think we walk that fine line
of you pinning some kind of
thing at the top versus what
we feel is recent.
We encourage to get
the most optimal.
On the recent posts, it's every
three days we think you
should post, because it's
the most relevant.
The other tip is, the About
section on your
Google+ page is SEO.
So the more robust that
description about your company
or app is, it discovers more.
It fires more.
Some of that content
gets brought in.
But we haven't quite, with the
advent of interactive posts, I
think we are toying with the
idea, well what could you pin
in there when that real estate,
and what does it look
like on mobile.
And so it's something
we're talking about.
But today, there's no way to
actually say, hey, I really
want to make sure that
people get to this.
But we definitely see it with a
lot of brands, whether it's
an Event or a Hangout or an
app download, that it's
something that we've
asked for.
And I think with the app stuff
you've seen, to be able to
download apps right there,
that's the first step.
Where our goal is to say, when
you search for that query,
what is the intent the
person wants to take?
And are we delivering that?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I think if
there's some big Event that's
coming up, that you're going
to be running, it would be
great to be able to make people
aware that that's the
thing that's going
to be happening.
MARVIN CHOW: Exactly.
And with interactive posts, that
may be easier, based on
query data and the
type of posts.
I think this is the thing,
this is the next step.
AUDIENCE: Right.
AMY WALGENBACH: Yeah, we're
really just getting started.
Yes, in the back.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
Syra from the Veterans
United Network.
I have a question about
YouTube Admin
Accounts and Hangouts.
So as a brand, we hire freelance
individuals in order
to drive our Hangouts, to
produce our Hangouts.
That also means you have to give
over your user name and
password to your YouTube
account.
In the future, might it be
possible to consider Admin
Accounts for those individuals
who are driving your Hangouts
so you don't have to give
over the keys to
your YouTube account.
MARVIN CHOW: So I think--
AMY WALGENBACH: We do
have page managers.
MARVIN CHOW: We do.
And I can follow up with
you separately on this.
I do believe, and I have to
check, if your pages are
merged, so if you've merged your
Google+ profile and the
account, you're giving them your
YouTube admin rights for,
because the upload should happen
automatically, so why
are you giving them YouTube
admin rights?
AUDIENCE: In order to launch the
Hangout On Air, you have
to give them your
YouTube login.
Because it streams on YouTube.
MARVIN CHOW: I think there
should be a better way to do
that, because we've seen in,
and if I can follow up with
you afterwards?
AUDIENCE: You betcha.
MARVIN CHOW: Yes.
Let's come on up and I'll try
to answer that question.
AMY WALGENBACH: Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: I was wondering if
there was any thought to
having the possibility of people
adding themselves to
your Circles, from a business
perspective?
Because one of the things that
a lot of us like to do is we
like to, when we post our
content, we know it's not
particularly interesting
to everybody.
Not everything is.
Some of it is, but
some of it's only
interesting to some people.
For an example, I do
legal information
online with my business.
And we put up case opinions
for various
courts around the country.
And some people are only
interested in the cases from
their court.
It would be nice if they could
add themselves to my circles.
We can create a circle for each
state, for example, and
say, California and say,
add yourself to
my California circle.
So that when I post California
case content, it goes to you.
But you don't have to just get
the general bulk feed of
everything.
AMY WALGENBACH: Yeah, we've
heard this request.
MARVIN CHOW: I think--
AMY WALGENBACH: Quite
a bit, actually.
MARVIN CHOW: It's a fantastic
question.
I think it really opens a
broader conversation of what
would be social CRM, is really,
you want to use
Google+ to how do you
build relationships
in niche ways across.
And we think it's an amazing
opportunity.
We haven't built the product
yet to do that.
And I think we're just
scratching the surface of this
idea of Circles and
how you share.
I think with some of the things
with Aspen and Sign In
and NFC, you could almost
imagine where, if you tap in,
that you just get automatically
added to a
Circle at an Event.
Or if you took an action
on a third party
website, we could do it.
So I think it's possible.
I think we haven't quite figured
out what is the right
model that the user would
understand and that was
actually useful for the
content creator.
But I think with a lot of brands
and app developers,
that idea that you have 10
million followers but you
don't want to send one thing
to 10 million people.
You do want to say, in a
particular state or maybe
someone who's purchased a
particular thing, you want to
send them something specific.
So it's something we've been
talking actively about.
We don't have the answer yet.
But we do see that social CRM
going down that road one day.
So maybe next year
at I/O, we'll
try to get you something.
AMY WALGENBACH: Yes, sir.
In the back.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name Yusef.
I'm from Animoca.
We are a game developer
in Hong Kong.
So most of the content on
Google+ is around the web and
mobile web.
But game developers, when
they're looking at content,
their user base, they basically
want them to be in-app.
So the question I have is,
growing our followers.
It's very easy for us to put a
Follow button in our game.
But currently, there is no
programmatic way to basically
add a follower.
And we don't want to throw the
gamer out of the game, into
the website, into the browser.
Then he'll never come
back again.
And the other question is, does
Google have policy on
incentivize use of social
[INAUDIBLE].
Can I say, get five virtual
coins if you follow me, two
coins if you basically
post something
about it on the Community?
Is there any policy
around that?
AMY WALGENBACH: So to
your first question.
You're saying that you want
people to follow you, add you,
add them to your Circles?
AUDIENCE: My game will
have a Google+ page.
Within my game, I want my users
to follow the page so I
can basically message them of
upcoming events, upcoming
promotions.
AMY WALGENBACH: They can, if
you have the Google+ badge,
they can add you directly to
their circles from your page
without them having to
leave your game.
MARVIN CHOW: I think it's, but
you're saying from within a
native app.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MARVIN CHOW: It's a really
good question.
I don't think we do it now, but
it's something I think we
can definitely look into.
AUDIENCE: Mobile game
developers don't have websites.
They typically don't.
MARVIN CHOW: Yeah, I think it's
a great request, and I
think we can definitely
look into it with
the platform team.
AUDIENCE: Now, what about the
policy with incentivize, use
of social [INAUDIBLE]?
MARVIN CHOW: That, I don't think
we have a policy against
that right now.
So I think it's something that
is definitely possible, as
long as it's using, obviously,
the native API calls and the
human posting algorithms.
AMY WALGENBACH: Yeah,
it's fine.
We don't have a policy
against it.
But--
We do.
We do have a policy.
MARVIN CHOW: We do,
apparently.
AMY WALGENBACH: Do not do it.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
So, a quick thing about
incentivization.
To incentivize a user to do
something that's spammy is
generally against our terms.
But to do something
that's meaningful.
Like if we all sign up for
this service, we get
something out of it.
Right?
Versus sending this to all your
friends, so they actually
click back to the app.
So.
AMY WALGENBACH: All right.
Sorry, we're out of time.
We'll be up here if you have
any other questions though.
Thank you.